hey there my name is Seth Juarez we're
at the 2015 microsoft research faculty
summit and I'm here with two of our
researchers so tell us about the project
you're working on we were looking at a
bunch of different phone applications
and we noticed they're all reading the
sensors and the sensors have a lot of
noise in them and we wanted to make
devices like the band and your phone
more energy-efficient and we realized
there was no way to trade off accuracy
or efficiency for quality of service
because there was no way to express it
in any of these languages and then we
realized not only sensors have this
problem but machine learning algorithms
are producing approximate answers and
also approximate computing is a new
mechanism for reducing computation to
gain energy efficiency and it also fell
in this peridot so then we're like we
need to start with the programming
language abstractions before we can
build systems that reason about this in
a principled wedding so let's start with
the actual sensor reading and why it's
inefficient so we're talking about GPS
specifically why is GPS so inefficient
when it comes to battery life so what
happens with GPS is when it needs to
contact a lot of satellites and the more
satellites you get the more accurate is
so that takes time because you know
you're communicating over a noisy
channel too many different satellites
and it takes time to communicate you
know do the triangulation itself so so
the process is just very energy if it
hung gree on your actual device there's
also a notion of uncertainty with these
types of reading isn't there so when the
GPS takes a reading there's some number
of satellites that are communicating it
each of them has a sense of what time it
is and then there's a delay they have
very accurate clocks but then it arrives
at your phone at different times and so
it can be cloudy a building can be
including one of the satellites and so
when that happens the GPS gets more and
more inaccurate and
everyone's had their car gps tell them
that they're driving in a field or in an
ocean and so that's a case where the GPS
can't produce an accurate accurate
reading and right now when you code one
of these applications like a navigation
application you essentially ignore that
data and trying to put yourself on a
road but even if you use good heuristics
for getting yourself back on the highway
and out of the ocean what happens is
it's all hand coded and not principled
and so so we trying to provide an
abstraction that reasons about the error
in these readings explicitly and makes
it easy for programmers to combine
domain knowledge such as roads the speed
you're traveling and the likelihood that
your your phone is in the ocean which
could happen if you step onto a boat but
is unlikely if the gps is installed in
your car so you're modeling this
uncertainty while at the same time
trying to lessen the toll on the actual
battery so is there a way to actually
know where you are without necessarily
having to ask GPS location is a pretty
abstract concept that many operating
systems would like to provide right and
GPS is just a mechanism to estimate your
location right but there are many other
ways and in fact there are many
researchers who spend a lot of time
thinking a very clever ways to estimate
location for instance you can use your
Wi-Fi to try and estimate you know hey
I'm in a building that I recognize I've
been in this building before or maybe I
just use the accelerometer on device i
took a GPS reading say five minutes ago
the accelerometer tells me that the
phone is probably not moved much so I'm
pretty likely to be where I was before
but you'll notice I use the word likely
so there is this notion of distribution
associated with all of these types of
estimates right and so that's what we're
trying to capture in the programming
abstraction where we don't want the
programmer to really have to reason
about what that distribution is right we
want the operating system providing
abstract location service
an error is encapsulated with those
particular types of ways that we would
estimate location so we keep talking
about abstraction and programmer using
the abstraction what is this abstraction
look like that you've been working on
for example the GPS error although what
they draw on your phone is a dot in a
circle it's actually a donut so the
donut around the point they draw is and
there's a little circle inner circle on
the donut which is where you're most
likely to be all right so you so that
district the donut distribution is
called a rolly distribution so you can
take samples from there that describe
the error and those are other locations
you're likely to be and then when you
make a decision like to draw a point on
a graph or or to compute how long you've
been running then you want to say how
likely is it that I've been that I want
to draw it on this road and then you can
explicitly reason about the fact that
hey this this point is very accurate
according to the gps so i can trust it
or it's not accurate and so I want to
maybe add domain knowledge like the road
where the road is and move the point to
snap to the row so you just have a
simple conditional that says what to do
when when when you want to add some
dimming knowledge so you mentioned to me
earlier that your language researchers
are you adding types or language
features that will enable this time of
uncertainty to be modelled well yeah we
have a generic type in c sharp and in
fact everything is in you know it's a
library in c-sharp our uncertainty
libraries and we so I think it's best
explained with with again GPS example
right so suppose that I want to compute
how fast I'm going my speed using to GPS
samples time taken it one gps sample
taken at time t0 and another one taking
at time t1 you know i would take those
due to gps locations compute the
distance and then use you know your
distance equals rate times time to
compute my rate
so what we do rate is a you know in that
program that I just described rate is a
float or double right but what we're
going to provide is because the original
we're going to give an abstraction over
location as an uncertain location and
we've done the appropriate operable
operator overloading in our types so
that you compute actually an uncertain
float for your rain right and so as a
consequence whenever you want to now act
on that data for instance use it in a
conditional to say whether or not I'm
you know if my speed is greater than
five miles an hour I might want to you
know post something to the users display
that actual that speed greater than five
miles an hour we use implicit type
conversions to actually do a hypothesis
test and try and statistically evaluate
whether or not we have enough evidence
to prove whether or not you're going
faster than five miles an hour so our
runtime you know so we have a library
that lets a programmer express this and
then a runtime that implements that
semantics that's awesome so as
researchers what's the future of this
kind of Reason what are you guys doing
in the future with this stuff so I think
there's a la challenges so this this
idea of domain knowledge composition I
think it's a very general principle a
lot of times you know much like when you
produce a library you don't know you
know you make a certain surface of API
calls that people can use and depending
on how a particular client uses that
those that surface you can do them all
of optimizations I think the same thing
goes to set be said with with this idea
of uncertainty right i mean again going
back the cheapest abstraction people use
that location service in various
different ways and coming up with really
efficient ways to encode that domain
knowledge of how they're actually using
that and then make the actual what
amounts to probabilistic inference
faster is under the hood we're really
doing probabilistic inference which is a
generally very hard problem and so we
need to come up with smart ways to take
what the programmer knows about their
domain and help and help will hopefully
come up with faster and efficient
implementations of that probabilistic
inference but more and more
application programmers are dealing with
estimated values they're consuming being
search results they're consuming machine
learning algorithms they're consuming
sensors so if they have to have a PhD in
statistics in order to correctly build
applications with these estimated values
either they're going to produce junk
because they're not going to do it at
all because they're going to just give
up and treat them as if they're facts or
they're going to or it's going to be an
arduous process and you're going to
always have to have a statistics PhD on
your application building team and so
what we're trying to do is provide some
abstractions where we bury the
complications that we've been talking
about in the runtime and the programming
language implementation but the
abstractions that the programmer gets to
use even though we probably could have
done a better job making them seem
straightforward are actually a lot more
straightforward than anything they could
do and then we want to embed them in
languages like C sharp Java C++ because
then they can be widely applicable in
application languages that lots of
people are using today because right now
there are some approaches that have
similar goals as as we do in terms of
representing uncertainty and
but call probabilistic programming
languages but we're kind of we kind of
just are a subset of that that is also
programmable for average programmers
rather than requiring both a PhD in
statistics and machine work well thanks
so much for spending some time with us
thanks for watching and we'll catch you
next time take care